what I want to do in this video is take
this quantity represented by these I
guess these greenish emerald looking
bars where each bar represents one and
try to represent them using the digits
that we know the digits 0 1 2 3 4 5 6 7
8 9 and the way I'm going to do it is
I'm going to group this into tens so I'm
going to see how many tens I have and
then essentially how many ones that I
have left over so let's try to group
this into groups of 10 so 1 2 3 4 5 6 7
8 9 let me actually I mess that up let's
see 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 so that's one
group of 10 right over there let me let
me let me box that off so you know that
that is 10 so that's one group of 10 now
let's see let's see if I can get a few
more groups of 10 in there 1 2 1 2 3 4 5
6 7 8 9 10
that's my second group of 10 right over
there second group of 10 and now let's
see it looks like I get several more
groups of 10 here 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10
so that's a third group of 10 it looks
like I might even be able to get one
more so that's my third group of 10 and
then we have 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 so
that's my fourth group of 10 fourth
group of 10 right over here so I was
able to fit in at least just this is one
this is a 10 right over here this is
another 10 right over here that's in the
third 10 and then that's the fourth 10
so we could say that's 10 plus 10 plus
10 or all of this combined all of this
combined is equal to 4 1 2 3 4 tens 4
tens but I'm not done I'm not done with
the number
still have one - I have two ones left
over so this is a one so that's a one
right over there and then this is
another one so that's another one so I
have two ones so this right over here
that is two ones remember each of these
little green bars we said represents a
one so this whole number is what well
it's going to be the four tens 1/10 2/10
3/10 is four tens plus the two ones so
let me write that down so it is four
tens plus plus two ones well what is
that well if we use the number systems
that we're used to representing we would
say well look our number system gives us
a way of representing that because the
first place the first place this is the
ones place so let me just in this blue
color so this is the ones place so there
we use one of the digits 0 1 2 3 4 5 6 7
8 9 to see how many ones we have and we
have two ones and then the next place
over to the left that's where we say how
many tens we have that's where we say
how many tens we have and we know how
many tens we have we have four tens so
the way that we would represent this in
our number system is we would say that
this is 4 tens and two ones and we call
this right over here we call this 42
another way that you could think about
this is four tens
well for tens that's 10 plus 10 plus 10
plus 10 that's going to be 40 so but
once again we're using our number system
to represent this and then we have two
ones and then we have two ones but I
like to write it this way just to remind
ourselves is four which represents four
tens
it also represents 40 because four tens
is 40